pour aller découvrir la recette de la
fouace cette pâtisserie typique de
l'aveyron je vais vous emmener
aujourd'hui dans une petite région qu'on
appelle les rives d'ault les rives du
lot
autrement dit qui sépare les causses de
l'aubrac
c'est une vallée heureuse où l'on a
toujours cultivé l'art du bien manger
c'est le pays des charcuteries en
particulier les tripoux l'ailé
fricandeau le jambon bien sûr les
saucissons et les saucisses sèches et
c'est surtout aujourd'hui le pays de la
fouace on la trouve partout cette fois
ce dans toutes les vitrines de boulanger
et de pâtissiers mais quelques femmes
continuent de la confectionner elle même
à la maison
plus spécialement dans les villages
isolés qui domine les rives du lot sur
les flancs de l'aubrac
nous sommes allés quant à nous chez
madame mercadier qui habite dans ce
village de naves de broc
un village qui n'est plus habitée
aujourd'hui que par trois ou quatre
familles mais où madame mercadier
maintien fidèlement la tradition de la
fouace
à
oui oui oui bonjour monsieur mercadier
devait bien madame mercadier bonjour
merci de nous avoir deux accepté de nous
montrer comment on fait la fouace donc
dans la période
et bien voilà alors vous avez sur la
table réunis là tous les ingrédients
nécessaires
oui d'abord de la levure que j'ai mis
dans mon saladier levure de boulanger de
boulanger combien 40 grammes pour le
kilo de farine qui leur farine qui est
là un verre de lait 6e 275 g de beurre
et 200 g de sucre une pincée de sel
c'est tout c'est tout ça suffit pour la
foi c'est tout ça suffit alors pourquoi
on commence eh bien on commence par
délayez la levure avec du lait avec le
vernis on dilue bien le lait froid ne
les tièdes tienne si possible tiers
requis et de wii party ça monte ça monte
au mieux mon nez puis je rajoute de la
photo et de la farine de façon à former
une pâte à pain une pâte à pain comme ça
je me débats toute la farine la non non
non non c'est pour commencer de faire un
levain donc première étape s'est remis à
l'étape cellules dans le levant alors
simplement les tièdes laitiers de levure
et farine alors combien de farine vous
mettez là où je sais pas 85 81 kg de
farine 3 250 grammes à peu près à peu
près
voilà c'est la fin de la première étape
on va laisser reposer ça pendant deux
milliards trois quarts d'heure à peu
près jusqu'à ce que la pâte est monté le
saladier presque plein un peu plus que
doublé devant l'une a vu un de plus que
doubler oui d'accord
bon ben mercadier pendant que le vin
travail
on a le temps de bavarder un petit peu
peut-être
[Musique]
et
m
ce village est tout petit siddharth brac
combien d'habitants hier je ne saurais
pas vous dire combien il ya d'habitants
il ya toit fermé encore acquis qui sont
exploitées trois petites fermes il fait
sans exploiter une série 3 est plus
importante
et puis puis à une soeur qui habite le
couvent tout seul il ya un monsieur qui
est encore retraités précédent - non
mais personne
c'est pas trop dur la vie dans ce
village marie est agréable il s'agit de
savoir l'apprendra du bon côté
[Musique]
après il a vanté trois quarts d'heure
ils ont découlé prêtant leur voix s'il
est bien monté voyez il a des traits qui
s'écartent là comme des crevasses ça
s'écarte un peu c'est que c'est qu'il
est prêt et voyez il fit le bien quand
on le dégage entre le dégage alors
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait se lever mais
dont il attend encore un peu
on va commencer le la pâte d'abord la
farine
ce conte ce qui reste de la farine de
riz bouilli ce qui restera farine bon
argent dedans on met le sucre 200 g de
sucre 100 g de sucre en poudre à un tour
de vis pas cristallisées parce que pour
aucune partie série ne se cristallise un
événement il y aura moins libre une
pincée de sel
je mets fondre le beurre dans une
casserole aussi au rappel de 175,7
approximative je le mets fondre sur le
feu et voilà puis je mets mes yeux mes
yeux là dedans 6,6 alors les 600 cas ces
récits se sont cassés je les bats un peu
de façon à ce que les blancs ne fasse
pas devenu mon petit peu ça se mélange
avec le sucre le sel
alors qu'est-ce qui intervient
maintenant
maintenant je mets le beurre fondu en
tournant toujours
tout y est là tout y est maintenant il
faut que je mélange le vin est pétri à
la main indispensable ça c'est
indispensable
je tends mon le vin ce que je sache qui
se détache bien et puis là il faut bien
pétrir ça ça demande combien un quart
d'heure mais tombe sans s'interrompre en
thèse honteuse un terrain de sienne a
quelque chose à faire monter quand on y
aller mais on préfère finir voyez il
faut bien faire attention que le vin
soit bien mélanger que ça fasse pas des
fils blancs dans la partie moyenne à oui
parce que le vin blanc et le reste est
jaune en soulevant plutôt que de
toujours tassé soulever un peu le
mélange et le ca prends davantage d'air
voyez la pâte et c'est l'air qui fait
l'époque et oui il a fallu relever qu'il
a fait bien levé c'est un truc de le
pâtissier en salle à l'autre je sais pas
qui vous a appris cette recette
d'ailleurs c'était recettes savez c'est
fois cela rend le pays ça s'est toujours
fait un peu à vis des motifs
alors chacun l'améliorent una on ne naît
pas de parfum à la fois dans la pâte
les boulangers à mettre tous les
boulangers mais tsubo la plupart de la
fleur d'oranger et certains maîtres de
la vanille mais moi je peux je prétendre
que c'est peut-être mon idée à moi que
la pâte se souvient c'est ça c'est des
tâches bien alors c'est vrai qu'en se
détache bien ça ne se comporte pas comme
vous le savez vous serez tous le tout le
bloc doit soulever bien aux eaux vous
pouvez y aller
ce sont des gens bien et voilà je pense
que ça doit donc comme ça alors qu'est
ce que vous allez en faire deux chiens
mais pas grave je vais laisser cette
pâte à se reposer jusqu'à ce qu'elle
sera environ la du plat à peu près trois
fois son volume 3 fois son volume actuel
à peu près et ça m'a demandé combien de
temps selon le degré de chaleur selon la
température de l'endroit où il sera 2
heures pas moins
il faut bien deux heures alors par un
peu de cette fois ce qui est une
pâtisserie typiquement aveyronnaise
oui aveyronnaise et lozériennes aussi
parce que c'est tout à fait limitrophes
la lozère oui alors c'est tout à fait
des deux départements
oui est ce ça se mange souvent ça à la
fois six autres fois ça se mange et
surtout les la fête village c'était le
gâteau traditionnel de la fête du
village de la paroisse pour ainsi dire
tous les villages de la paroisse s'est
pas de luxe un plat de luxe
peut-être pas de luxe mais le plat
traditionnel si le gâteau traditionnel
de la fête du village à la fin des
moissons la souligner que qu'on appelait
alors la fin des foins ou des moissons
sont encore en droit il y avait encore
la fois soyons danser là
[Musique]
c'est traditionnel depuis très très
longtemps je me rappelle en avoir
entendu parler l'histoire d'un d'un
musicien qui venait de jouer un mariage
pour vous faire danser les jeunes
et puis l'arrivée loup qui les suivait
derrière il portait de la fois ci leur
donner un morceau de fouace et de temps
en temps et puis quand il a eu fini ne
savait plus que leurs données et les
loups étaient toujours à ses trousses à
laurie s'est mise à lui joué de la
cabrette et ils ont fuit et il a dit si
j'avais su j'aurais joué plus tôt et je
regardais ma foi c'est parce que la fois
c'était quelque chose de précieux et oui
parce que dans toutes les maisons vous
savez il y avait beaucoup de monde dans
les maisons mais il y avait beaucoup de
monde dans les villages rapport ouais et
beaucoup de monde dans les maisons et
l'argent était l'argent était rare s'il
y avait une douzaine de vie santé oms
faisait la galette de blé noir par
exemple qui ne demandait pas beaucoup de
la fois ce qui demandait beaucoup de
beurre beaucoup d'eux c'était vraiment
pour les jours de fête
alors là mercadier la pâte la reposer
pendant deux heures environ parce que ça
dépend de l'endroit où il entrepose de
la chaleur que que dégage la source
ça dépend de plusieurs choses de la
fraîcheur dans le vercors
alors à quoi on le voit que la pâte est
vrai talent à elle a bien gonflé et là
un peu plus que doublé de vous deux
volumes presque triplé voyez plutôt
il faut qu'elle soit bien montée bien
lisse voilà qu'est ce que vous allez et
là je fais une couronne que je retourne
c'est là la forme classique de la fouace
commandes devraient dessiner une croix
au couteau dans le centre de la toile
oui vous avez retourné je retourne les
boues qui gonfleront bien ça fait la
vertu voilà ou alors on peut aussi faire
carrément un lourd face voilà comme ça
c'est sarah aussi et puis on en taille
pour que ça n'éclate pas de surveiller
les les entailles s'ouvriront c'est
comme le pain je vais se reposer sans
petit moment que ça reparte voyait que
que ça lève encore un peu on les sent
que reposait un quart d'heure vingt
minutes aux choses toujours toujours
chaud je le pense que la cuisine
comme ça là ça sera presque trop chaud
là et puis voilà vous avez faire la
fouace aussi vous monsieur mercadier à
bon port mais pourtant vous l'avez vu
faire souvent noir oui soit dans le
chaland la cuisinière avant parce que
sinon vous êtes bien placés là c'est
votre place habituelle près de la
cuisinière deux fois oui pas toujours
d'un côté il ya la fois ce qui lève et
de l'autre côté il ya monsieur mercadier
le choix de pâtes au bout mais voulait
mais la fois c'est quand même un diable
oui c'est vrai madame mercadier c'est
près ma patte à vienne opposée elle
commence à monter je la met au fond
alors ça c'est le four électrique
je les met donc un terme aux stars à
thermostat 8 oui et vous allez c'est
combien de temps là dedans au 20 minutes
environ 20 minutes et celle ci c'est le
four à bois
on ne peut pas vivre un temps défini
parce que le trouble à bois il n'y a pas
de thermostat
alors ça va plus ou moins vite il faut
surveiller je surveillais à quelle
occasion plutôt en deçà de toute façon
nous fait ça que pour le fait d'y aller
ou sur la peine
mais on lui présente un procédé
ingénieux électrique et maintenant on la
mange n'importe quel jour le jour
c'est un droit voilà il ya quelque chose
madame mercadier qu'on peut pas faire
partager aux téléspectateurs et c'est
dommage mais c'est l'odeur de cette fois
déjà pendant que ça tient on attendait
de sa dette à l'heure annoncée oublié
est-ce que du sirop un silo de sucre
c'est à dire du secret de la recette du
chic avec des mots la causerie de plus
j'avais zappé dix ans ah oui l'odeur
extraordinaire plus le brillant alors la
tâche très envie de la manger madame ait
raté père vous avez la goûter c'est la
traditionnelle
oui on ne peut faire toutes les
fantaisies en france mais la forme
traditionnelle c'est celle-là avec quoi
ça se mange la fois s'enthousiasme
enjeux de préférence avec une crème avec
une mousse au chocolat c'est très bien
c'est pas faire une mousse au chocolat à
la fin du repas oui on va pouvoir le
manger maintenant voyez l'état vilaine
superbe
est-ce que la fois ce que fait banal
mercadier est la meilleure arme pour moi
oui vous n'avez jamais trouvé deux fois
meilleure que celle là dessus
sa seule canal bishop oui souvient la
place de pour la meilleure
[Musique]